threats in the wake of bin Laden's death
have Speight famine in Somalia police
pepper spray vicious cartels [ __ ] the
crew tries to scientistic a 65 dead
tsunami warning cyberattacks drug war
mass destruction tornado recession Defoe
Jews de Egypt Syria crisis death
disaster oh my god
hi i'm tim cavanaugh a reason TV we're
here with Peter Diamandis who is the
author of the new book abundance the
future is better than you think can you
give us a brief description of what the
book is sure a lot of people think that
the world is getting worse but they're
wrong the world is actually getting
better at an extraordinary rate and an
accelerating rate of human lifespan over
the last hundred years has more than
doubled childhood mortality rate has
decreased by 90% the per capita income
per person adjusted for inflation is
tripled a Masai warrior in the middle of
Kenya on a smartphone today on a cell
phone has better mobile communications
and President Reagan did 25 years ago
and if they're on Google on a smartphone
they have access to more information and
knowledge than President Clinton 15
years ago but the reality is that as
humans we're constantly fed all of this
negative information by media because
that's what our brain preferentially
looks for because we evolved to watch
for negative information as a survival
technique there is a real disconnect
that humans have with reality today an
American under the poverty line the
poorest of the poor here in America
still have running water flushing toilet
air conditioning cell phones majority
have access to a car they're living with
a set of capabilities that the
wealthiest people on the planet 150
years ago the robber barons the monarchs
and emperors would have been jealous oh
we keep on moving this line of what
poverty means so this book actually
talks about how the world is getting
better and what if the force is driving
us that way the first force driving us
towards abundance is rapid exponentially
growing technology all of these things
on Moore's law of faster and faster
computers that are enabling artificial
intelligence and robotics and digital
medicine and synthetic biology these are
forces and capabilities that are
literally allowing individuals and small
teams to do what only governments and
large corporations could once
those technologies are being used by the
second Force which is the DIY innovator
the guy in the gal who's driven by their
passion to want to solve Grand
Challenges who are now able to do
extraordinary things but the third force
is what I call the techno
philanthropists today there is more
wealth in the hands of individuals than
ever before and these people are making
their wealth at a younger age in their
20s and 30s and during an era of really
social consciousness where instead of
building buildings to their names people
are saying I want to solve this disease
or change education or healthcare the
final force perhaps the biggest is what
I call the rising billion the notion
that on earth we had 2 billion people
connect on the Internet in 2010 it's
growing from 2 billion to 5 billion
people by 2020 3 billion new minds are
being connected on the Internet these
are people who've never been heard from
before they're going to become a massive
economic force they're gonna be an
economic dividend from these people as
they begin to consume and buy and create
an invent and generate value around the
around the world and people say what is
the poorest people on the planet how can
they possibly have you know a real
economic impact with a few billion
people who live on 3 to 5 dollars a day
spending you know a dollar or two a day
per year that's trillions of dollars
flowing into the economy one of the
points of the book is that technology
actually expands resources and things
that we think of as sort of speed limits
are actually more of a malleable than we
thought
technology is sort of a scarcity
liberating process and you know the the
book is wrapped in a simulation of
aluminum plant and the first story talks
about the fact that in the 1840s
aluminum was more valuable than gold and
platinum see even though the earth
physically is 8.3% aluminium by weight
all the aluminum is bound as bauxite no
bound by oxygen and silicates and so you
don't find aluminum in pure form in the
earth
and was very expensive to purify and so
was the most precious pure metal on the
planet and then the process of
electrolysis came along and made
aluminum so cheap
we have aluminum foil in cans we don't
think about anymore the same will happen
in many fields take energy for example
we talked about having energy scarcity
even though the human race uses the 16
terawatts of energy today
there's 16 terawatts of energy from the
Sun that hits the earth every 88 minutes
we have 6,000 times more solar energy
that hits planet Earth than we consume
the challenge is it's not in usable form
last year for example in 2011 the cost
of solar energy fell by 50% to the point
where in India today it's half this
cheap to get your electricity from solar
than from diesel generators and that
trend will continue the news feeds us up
the negative stories but not that a
breakthrough is going on in synthetic
biology being able to convert you know
solar energy through algae to food and
fuels far more efficiently take food for
example we had a green revolution which
has allowed us to feed the world far
more efficiently and all of the horrors
around genetically engineered food never
panned out there's more GE crops than
ever before and it's because of them
that we can feed people as well as we do
but that's just the beginning of the
innovation that we have you know we're
going from literally evolution by
natural selection which is Darwinism to
evolution by intelligent direction there
is technology right now in synthetic
biology and biotech engineering that's
going to allow us to convert that energy
process a hundred to ten thousand times
more efficiently and what that means is
we're going to be able to create foods
that are more flavorful better for you
more nutritious more efficient more
available than ever before we're also
going to start to change where the food
is made so one of the great ideas that
we speak about in the book is vertical
farming you know when you sit down at a
meal today
the average food that you're eating is
traveled some thousands of miles
extraordinary expense we are going to be
moving to world where we can actually
create that food source locally far more
efficiently far more nutritionally as
well and this is some fundamental change
in the way we're going to feed people
over the next few decades people talk
about the potential for water wars the
fact that we're living in a in a scarce
water environment in abundance I talked
about the fact that we're really living
on a water planet do you think about the
fact that 70% of the planet is covered
by water the problem is that 98% of it
is saltwater the remaining 2% that's
fresh water the majority of that is the
polar caps so half a percent of the
water on this planet is the freshwater
one of the DIY innovator is dean caiman
has developed a technology called
slingshot which is a device the size of
your dorm room refrigerator that is able
to literally take any source of wet
saltwater the latrine arsenic infected
water the most polluted water the planet
and turn that water into the purest
possible drinking water for less than
two cents a liter
what are so pure you can inject it into
you I want you to imagine this kind of
technology in every village around the
planet offering them water and an
extraordinary cheap price much cheaper
than we buy it in the United States
what about street parking or beachfront
property or the things that we would not
it doesn't really seem like there's
anywhere you can expand that supply take
street parking as the example we are
within a decade away from having cars
that are using artificial intelligence
that robotic cars the cars you and I
drive but they're fully automated so
once you imagine a world you don't have
to own a car anymore you go on your
iPhone you pull it up and you say I need
a Ferrari today because I'm taking
someone on a date
and a Ferrari drives up picks you up and
you rent it if you would by the hour or
I need an SUV because my family's coming
into town and you don't actually park a
car what you do is the car drops you off
and then goes and does something else
useful for the next five hours until you
need it again you know your car is 95
percent fallow it's sitting in a parking
lot or in your driveway for 95s in that
time use 5% what a wasted resource
imagine if the other 95% of the time
it's off doing useful work for somebody
else a lot of people are mad that banks
and General Motors and so forth have
been rewarded for their failure to adapt
and have gotten bailed out and do we owe
anything to people who are getting
displaced for us to prop up an industry
which is the old-school industry in a
world that is exponentially growing is a
real failure mode you know it's much
better to say listen instead of building
cars that could be built much better in
other parts of the world much cheaper
let's instead get into the you know
solar energy business or the battery
business and so forth yes it would be
great to have a industrial base United
States but does it have to be for a
hundred year old technology or can it be
for something that we really can do much
better here I'd rather be investing
capital in things that are transforming
the economy like what happens at a
Silicon Valley I mean people forget how
extraordinary the innovation coming out
of Silicon Valley in the creation of
Google and eBay and Facebook and all of
the internet companies that are propping
up our economy is that's where we should
be investing capital that's where we
should be creating jobs not you know
manual labor that is soon to be replaced
by robots and artificial intelligence
now we see this flow of jobs from the
United States to China or India because
labor rates are cheaper there what
happens when labor is robots and the
cost of electricity in China in the u.s.
is the same and so the robot being in
downtown - Kip see or in Shanghai
doesn't matter add to that you know 3d
printing and 3d manufacturing the
ability to literally come up with
something think about on the computer
print it out see if it looks good
iterate rapidly
we're going to see extraordinary
innovation ultimately I can't tell you
what the breakthroughs are going to be
because the rate of innovation is so
fast the challenges and what scares me
tremendously especially here in the
United States is that the government
can't keep up with it but we're living
in the world where when you say stem
cell research is illegal in the United
States all you're saying is okay top
scientists go and do your research in
South Korea or China or India it doesn't
stop it from happening
it just goes someplace else my concern
is that the rate of change is so fast
that the government's gonna have a hard
time dealing with this so as an example
we have partnered with Qualcomm Paul
Jacobs CEO and I were on the stage at
the opening of the Consumer Electronics
Show in Las Vegas asking teams to build
a handheld device that puts it
healthcare in the palm of their hands it
would be a device that is consumer
friendly your wife your mom your kids
could use you can call on to talk to it
you know do a transdermal blood analysis
and it will diagnose you better than a
board-certified doctor what happens now
does that be coming does your phone
become an FDA regulated device and can
the FDA really figure out how to
regulate that so fast or does that
technology actually get launched in
Africa or China or someplace else first
before the regulations can catch up with
it here in the United States and all of
a sudden you've got better health care
in the developing world than you do here
you go to the doctor now you may have a
series of tests a cat scan
scan of genomics scan a blood analysis
and so forth there's literally gigabytes
of data no doctor can analyze that it
really is going to take an artificial
intelligence to look at all the
information and be able to evaluate you
by 2020 we're going to be short ninety
one thousand doctors the United States
we have an overloaded emergency room
it's a broken system the only hope that
I see is gonna be see is going to be
these AIS these tricorder devices I hope
we're not going to be in a situation
where entrenched interests are
preventing the consumer from having
better health care so we're gonna be
transforming medicine in a big way
there is always a critical mass of
people who are willing to believe the
whole argument that's you know present
company excepted most people are too
stupid to handle all of this information
that's why they need the experts to do
it for them that's sad
man it's it's sad and and all that will
happen is we'll have better health care
in other parts of the world and that
will just get people to stand up and
notice and revolt but it's too late at
that point we've lost our edge I'm kind
of tired of people going back and oh it
used to be such a simple wonderful life
in the 1800s and so forth yeah when your
life expectancy was 35 and you know you
came down a disease that we can cure now
and it killed you back then and you the
child mortality rate was 25% a quarter
of your kids would die I mean if you
want the kind of nostalgia that's great
I guarantee you that they're very happy
to other cell phones and email and being
able to go and Google something and
order it on Amazon and have it arrive
the next day if they want to give that
up there is the potential to go live a
life without technology it's not forced
on you I best describe myself as a
libertarian capitalist if in fact the
world is innovating and moving forward
as an American and as a
an entrepreneur I want America to to
take its values of democracy and
capitalism and and move them forward the
reason that we are speaking English in
the United States is because the
exploring ships out of China turned
around in the 13 and 1400s otherwise
they would have colonized the rest of
the world we be speaking Mandarin
thousands of years from now people look
back at his next few decades as the
moment in time that the human race moved
off the planet there is always gonna be
ups and down to the economy but on the
whole our ability to gain access to the
basic needs food water housing health
education is getting better and better
and better